hi everyone I'm here today at the
University of Sydney with my friend
Peter who is a PhD student in physics
education hello hello let him explain
what he does hi so I am a PhD student in
physics education and my research is
focused on figuring out how to make
better physics education multimedia also
known as I try to figure out how YouTube
works but end up not making any yeah so
you've done a little bit of work with
like analyzing YouTube videos yeah so I
my my supervisor actually was also the
supervisor of a certain Derek Muller of
veritasium Fame oh sorry sorry Dirk from
varus table Liam Fame and yeah that's
actually how I heard of the the program
over and you said and that's why I came
over from Perth to stop my PhD and yeah
I'm studying how to not just create
videos that teach concepts in physics
but also encourage I know reflective
thinking and critical thinking and
looking into facts and checking if
they're legitimate or not and those kind
of things so so I thought we'd talk
about something that is related to
learning physics and that is the idea of
thinking like a physicist
so it's something that I've sort of
heard along with my physics education is
that what people are trying to teach you
is not just you know to memorize facts
about mechanics or certain physical
systems but to think in a way that a
physicist would so what is that
statement mean to you so for me and kind
of like encapsulates the whole idea that
science is not a collection of facts
it's not an encyclopedia it's a way it's
a systematic way of looking at the world
and trying to understand how it works
so for me it's like as a person that's
being trained
hopefully relatively well to think like
a physicist that means that I get good
at estimating things and checking like
dimensions right and dimensional
analysis and just kind of going is this
a reasonable number when you come out of
your physics degree like physics is such
a broad discipline you could never learn
all of it but if you can learn to think
in this way then at least you can tackle
and approach these ideas on your own so
I know I've been involved in tutoring a
course that has a focus on estimation so
we give the students the problem of how
many piano tuners are there in this city
and at first when you hear that it might
seem a bit overwhelming you're like I
don't know but if you can start from
something you do know maybe an estimate
of the population maybe an estimate of
how many people would have pianos you
can work from there and get something
that's reasonable mm-hmm so basically
the kind of the class of these kind of
estimation problems is called fermi
problems after the the Italian physicist
nobel prize laureate and rico fermi and
there's actually a fascinating book
about him called the pope of physics
which i recommend everyone should check
out on audible.com which is not just yet
not just yet but there's an amazing
story about him when he worked on the
Manhattan Project where all the
scientists were trying to figure out
like the yield of the the Trinity test
like how big was this explosion going to
be and you know kilograms of TNT right
and everyone was kind of having like
this discussion and they were doing all
mathematical calculations and one of the
things that Fermi did was during the
explosion he held up a piece of paper
and he tore it into a smaller piece and
he held it up in the air and he dropped
it and instead of dropping straight down
it because of the shockwave
it dropped sideways and he you know
measured out the number of paces and you
know in his mind did a quick calculation
did a quick estimation and was able to
get within a factor of two right which
is really cool that you can measure the
yield of an atomic bomb with a piece of
paper yeah I think when you do something
like that order of magnitudes are all
that matter like if something's 87 just
round it to 100 and the same as like if
something's 4 that's actually closer to
10 just use 10 like yeah for sure oh so
many engineers are gonna laugh at us but
yeah I think I think there's like this
other thing that we are taught as
physicists is not to kind of it's not
just to kind of blindly believe things
right like if someone tells you a fact
your brain should light up and go where
did they get this back from how was the
research conducted who's paying for it
right like what are the kind of biases
in that and then the other thing is like
trying not to fool yourself there's a
Fineman quote of you know science is
about trying not to fool yourself and
you're the easiest person to fool and
sorry to make this into invoker
recommendation a book but if you haven't
read Thinking Fast and Slow brilliant
such a good book yeah I think some of
those like estimation type problems too
like they're not unique to physics it's
it's thinking critically in general and
of course it applies to lots of fields
I've heard people say that like the
questions they ask you at Google
interviews are like this they're sort of
absurd
estimations but once you boil it down to
like a few steps and make a few
assumptions you can actually think quite
critically about a lot of things in the
world around us yeah for sure for sure
I'll post a link to Peter's Twitter down
on the bio and anything else he works on
so you can check them out there yeah
thanks for watching thank you very much